this is a beautiful book we've done a
great job but who cares
and he looked at me and he went what do
you mean who cares and i said how are we
gonna make this something
that stands out amid all the other
people that thought
that they should write a memoir because
he's not famous
what are some common mistakes you see
new writers make that once they're at a
professional level
you don't see as much so what would so
professional levels an
interesting term because what would that
be
i mean i i say to um my clients
the minute you've made a decision to
write a book you are now a professional
author and you need to think that way
and if you have to take a post-it and
you have to put it on your desk that
says i am a
professional author or i am an author
you need to do that you need to put it
everywhere in your house
until you actually believe that you are
of the same quality as anybody else
there's no like distinction between you
and the person who's super famous or as
a new york times bestseller
you have to own that within you first
and i think once they step to that
then it's really just it's time to work
on the craft
and there's certain writers that take to
this the art of writing like a duck to
water
they will take direction really quickly
they'll you know they're not afraid of
us doing a first draft
and then me saying okay let's rip it
apart because
the middle of the book should be where
we start the book and this see this
chapter should mix with this chapter and
i think we might need a different ending
because that's what happens when you do
the first draft the second draft is
really where the magic happens there are
some people that are not afraid of that
they're like let's they roll up there
let's let's do it and there's other
people that are like
oh my god what does that mean like we
just i just did this for like 12 weeks
now you're gonna
we're gonna rip it apart what is that
and there's a lot more fear
of the process right which is
understandable because
they just did a process that they were
not comfortable with they just they're
like
oh phew i just got through that and now
we have oh there's another process
but inevitably everybody at the end of
the second draft
sees the light at the end of the tunnel
no matter where they were in the first
draft they're all like
this is good some are more like
a little bit like we're on to something
and other other people are like oh my
god this is like
so excited like this is magic like magic
has happened
so i think by the end of the second
draft they all kind of feel like
professional writers
some of them might hang on a little bit
to
uh they might start to as it gets closer
to like going out and looking for a
publisher
well do you think my writing's good like
are you sure it's up to standard do you
think my writing is good enough
and you know it's just assurance it's
like it's not that you're right it's not
whether your writing is right or wrong
it's are you communicating in a clear
entertaining and effective way
something that's going to inspire the
reader and drive them to take some kind
of
action in their life right like uh
maybe you're you're you're espousing
some kind of new philosophy have you
done a good enough
job having them actually sit up and go i
never thought about that
i'm gonna i'm gonna change the way i do
that in my life
which is what a lot of great books will
do
why would someone be afraid to go
through the first draft
whereas others are like yeah let's do it
rip it apart like
tell me the truth i think just that that
there's
that there is a banality even there's
like a conflict right
so on one hand they've been told
for years by everybody under the sun
you should write a book and so they
believe and then there's
underneath a little part of them that
believes that right but they're coming
in
a little bit driven on external
forces right so they'll come in and
they'll be like
okay well i'm gonna do it kind of
because everybody else said i should do
it
and i kind of believe i should do it so
i'm going to write this thing
but there's in the back of their mind
still that like
self-defeating mindset that's like
and it's often can be a voice that says
who cares does this really matter
like you're spending all this time and
energy like putting this out because
what the valet
said you should write a story because
your aunt mary said you should write a
story
i don't know this seems like a lot of
time and a lot of you're spending a lot
of time with that kim lady
how do you even know she's qualified
like
what even are her credentials and i joke
about this sometimes when i do talks
about what that voice will do to try to
keep you safe right because you've been
safe
you've gotten so far your ego's like
we're cool
we're good and all of a sudden you're
like but i actually want to tell them
that he goes like
no wait a minute we've been good without
you telling all these stories why do you
want to upset the apple cart now
so that's more what i see coming into
play and it comes in all different ways
it comes in
tears it comes in argumentativeness
it comes in you know i see it all i have
a lot of very strong
willed personality clients and i see it
come out in all different ways
what about a third draft oh the third
draft is just heaven
because we've ripped it apart we've put
it back together we know exactly
what the book is and now we get to do
like a lot of bells and whistles
so um maybe we didn't find
a system in the book that we knew would
have to be there
i used my client alan maxwell a lot for
this example
he had written a a memoir about his life
from philadelphia to becoming a top
defense contractor in san diego in the
navy in between
and we were done with the third draft
and i said
we've done a beautiful book we've done a
beautiful job this is someone who knew
nothing about writing and dictated most
of his book and we had to like do a lot
of fixing on it but
got it done in the airport on a busy
schedule
and i said this is a beautiful book
we've done a great job but
who cares and he looked at me and he
went
what do you mean who cares and i said
how are we gonna make this something
that stands out amid all the other
people that thought
that they should write a memoir because
he's not famous
and i said every time you write
something you talk about a system
that you've been in whether it's various
parts of the navy
or parts of society in georgia
or the government and i said
you've got some rules that you've
applied in your life to get through
those situations that you've then
carried into new situations
how many do you think you might have of
those rules he said i don't know let me
go let me go
figure it out so we came up with 15
rules
we then went back through the book on a
fourth draft
found all the places the rules would
apply and put them into the book and he
became a wall street journal top 10
business book
wow so we went from great this is your
life
it very interesting but who are you and
why should we
be dialed in to then you tapped into
that
a lot of rules structures things in
place interesting
yeah and we made it something that was
for anybody like
we had a 17 year old girl read it and
she was just blown away
yeah she was like i would take this as
my book that i would bring out into the
world and use
because if you think about it anytime we
step into anywhere
if you have these tips that he gives and
you understand these rules apply
and you're savvy with them you can
figure out who your allies are who your
enemies are
you know you can figure out you can keep
your eyes open and attuned to certain
certain situations see the red flags
you're going to do pretty well
interesting so was it was it too vanilla
before or it was still interesting but
he wasn't giving the reader anything
exactly okay
and so is that something that could be
as we all think our lives are
fascinating and okay they won't make a
movie about me but maybe if i write my
book they'll they'll right
right but but is is that what sometimes
we're missing is what are we offering
the reader what are we offering the
reader and he
actually has some discreet chapters
that are standalone movies without a
doubt i mean he has
you know uss destroyers getting
song i mean he has very exciting moments
but that wasn't enough
right it's great to read that that adds
to his credibility
with his knowledge that he's sharing but
standalone it wasn't
a hundred percent enough um when people
come to me
write memoirs i do say what do you think
are your like
core areas that you have
the the golden thread or the line of
something your whole life you've kind of
not paid attention to so it might be
money messaging from childhood and then
money chaos money chaos money chaos
money chaos till finally
they changed something and now they
might not
still be great with money but they
they're free right
and then all the scenes support that
through line someone could read that and
see their money stories
and see their pattern and so it's like
they they
they are able to have like some kind of
epiphany a recovery or learning curve
through being entertained in that
narrative
you